hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the brand new insta360 one
rs this is the second version of this
camera to come out and i might be one of
the i guess self-proclaimed biggest
insta360 fans i have pretty much every
single one of their cameras since the
very beginning and i'm such a huge fan
of these mostly because of the way that
they integrate so well with the apps on
your phone i can basically go out and
shoot an entire feature film get really
cool creative shots right here send it
to my phone edit them on the fly and
have some really cool content to post so
first let me unbox and show you
everything that it comes with
[Music]
so this is the insta360 one rs twin
edition and this camera is incredible
because it can become a bunch of
different things all in one this comes
with a 4k boost lens a 360 degree lens
and a lens cap this upgraded core is the
brains of the camera and this is where
all of the processing happens this gives
you the ability to have smooth
stabilization and faster wi-fi transfer
the 4k boost lens is a half inch sensor
the 360 lens is a 5.7 k giving you the
ability to get some really creative and
wild shots the battery is also bigger
with 21 more capacity with the 4k boost
lens you can also shoot 4k 60 frames a
second and you can take 48 megapixel
photos i'm a huge fan of flow state
stabilization and this is built in to
give you instant gimbal-like
stabilization
you can switch the lenses on the fly so
you'll pretty much be getting two
cameras in one
[Music]
there's a bunch of new accessories like
this quick reader and the new mounting
bracket is also improved one of my
favorite things about this camera is
there's an invisible selfie stick in
real life yes you can see it but inside
of the app it's able to use ai to remove
it
[Music]
i love shooting in 360 because when i'm
actually editing this on my phone i can
choose the shots after the fact so i am
essentially fixing it in post now that
everything's unboxed it's time to start
testing i'm actually out here with my
friend armando and we're shooting a
review of my tesla he's actually the
reason that i bought the tesla in the
first place so it's only fitting that
we're back here testing it he is also
working on an insta360 one rs video so
he's gonna be helping me get some really
cool shots of my tesla and i'm also
gonna be showing you some of the really
cool creative shots that you can get
with this camera so let's get to it
setting up my camera to go out and test
and this is one of my favorite features
that they change from the 3ds version
this is their quick release cage it also
has a new heat dissipating technology
because sometimes when you have action
cameras inside of cases they tend to get
really warm and that will hinder the
performance the previous one was very
tedious you had to like i don't even
think i could i can't even open it
that's how much i don't like it so for
as much as i didn't like the old version
i love this new one so check this out so
the quick release because this is
modular you just push the button
take it out change your lenses and
you're good to go now you'll see that i
already have this rigged with the quick
release cage and it has just the
standard gopro mounts and this is the
insta360 stick and this is what kind of
makes the 360 magic all happen because
when you're shooting in 360 they are
able to digitally remove the stick so it
kind of just looks like you're floating
or you have a drone following you and
that's my favorite thing about this
camera are the cool shots that you can
get that
no other camera really can do and as for
a comparison i brought the old insta 360
1r and this actually has the one-inch
sensor on it and like i said because the
accessories work from the old version
the fact that i can use all of the old
pieces and accessories that i have with
the old camera is pretty exciting looks
like i'm all set up ready to go the
first lens that i have on here is the
360 lens so let's go get some cool shots
and see how it looks
[Music]
so these are some of the really cool ai
features that you can do using their
shot lab and it's awesome because they
give you an example of it and then they
show you a tutorial on exactly how to do
it so i'm going to give you guys a
little example of how to do a couple of
these there's one that i am so hyped
about this is called the clone trail and
it'll basically make a clone of yourself
just using this and the app so we'll
test it out this is actually another
accessory that they have this little
stick turns into a tripod which is great
for these types of shots because it
allows you to have a built-in tripod
with your selfie stick
[Music]
okay insta360 has this thing called flow
state stabilization and they have pretty
much perfected it over the past couple
of years so when you're using this
camera you can be running jogging
swimming biking snowboarding doing all
kinds of crazy action sports or you know
just walking around town reviewing the
camera but it gives you this incredible
stabilized footage and that's what
they're calling flow state stabilization
so with that you're able to do all these
amazing activities and it looks like you
have a drone following you because it's
so incredibly smooth so now that you
guys have seen the 360 in action it's
time to swap out the lens for the 4k
boost lens and this is awesome because i
have
right now three cameras in one another
thing that i like is you can switch this
lcd to face you or be away from you so
if i want to do a little front-facing
video i can actually see if i'm in frame
or if i'm filming in front of me i can
have it behind me so i can actually see
what i'm shooting time to vlog and what
better time to start vlogging when
there's terrible audio right next to a
big loud truck
but you know that's all in the joy of
testing because now i can see what my
voice sounds like
next to oh my let's keep it up so now
this is the 4k boost lens now i'm
curious to see what it looks like in
comparison to the one inch sensor so
let's swap that out really really quick
and just like that the one inch sensor
is now on i'm honestly really enjoying
this so much more than the first version
of this everything i feel like i was
complaining about in the first version
of this camera they fixed it i've had so
much fun testing out this camera and to
end this video first of all a huge thank
you to insta360 for sponsoring this
video you guys are the best and i had so
much fun testing this camera out we have
one mounted in the back and we're gonna
mount one here in the front and we're
gonna end this video with drag strip
mode so in my car i have the tesla model
s plaid and in drag strip mode you can
go from 0 to 60 in 1.9 seconds so i
thought we gotta test it out so here we
go you want to ring it up let's do it
okay cool do it this is gonna be awesome
okay go for it
[Music]
okay we're gonna put this in drag strip
mode and i've only done this once before
it was basically the day after i got
this so i'm so much more comfortable
with this vehicle now so i am ready
to go
ready to launch
head back
okay slow down
oh
wow that was brutal
okay i promised myself that i was going
to keep going and if i would not have
kept breathing
i would have passed out
not even joking
[Music]